hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the market-leading mousy
biotyper ca system past present and
future
i am marie stone of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by brooker to learn more visit
brooker.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr marcus costazzeva
vice president r d
regulatory and scientific affairs
brooker diatonics microbiology and
diagnostics
dr costazeva you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the kind introduction
and i'm responsible at brooker
microbiology diagnostics for all
innovations
ladies and gentlemen i'm happy that
today i can
guide you through a story to a journey
from the introduction of models of mass
spectrometry into clinical microbiology
up to its state of the art today and
even want to give you a glimpse about
the future of the multiplied hyper
system specifically for multibitable ca
for diagnostic use in the united states
so let's jump at first a little bit in
the past
so how and when it started that was in
the middle of the 1990s
when several publications came up
that described the usage of modes of
mass spectrometry
for regenerating fingerprints specific
for microbes
interestingly
three or four
important publications came from the
united states so one can say what we do
today
had its origins indeed in the united
states you see these publications
and
one of those came from united kingdom
using a somewhat different method which
later on did not make it through
also after that further people in the
united states especially worked on this
topic
so some
names we should always remember like
arnold and rayleigh working on this very
early in 1998
very important plumbing demirov and
katherine fenslau who did great work on
the basics of this
then also very future guiding
german and val
setting some real
milestones in the development of
microbiology biomotive mass spectrometry
and again here a publication
where drama demographic is part of
together with pineda
guiding also to some future
bioinformatics for analysis of the
spectra
but
this did not make it to the routine
others published but its state in mass
spectrometry mainly did not enter
microbiology
because at that time the established
standard
in the laboratories
by far automated was biochemical testing
maybe
by
chemical testing it ultimates like the
vitac 2
or microscan
phoenix and others
they were automated but took several
hours mainly overnight for analysis for
identification
the costs per sample were quite
significant the accuracy also was
partially limited especially for some
particular groups
and they normally had to be supplemented
by manual larger other visual tests to
be complementary and add information for
better identification
these methods all were relatively slow
and
especially it was difficult to identify
other ropes yeast or other fungi
mycobacteria the gold standard giving
best results was dna sequencing already
that time but that was not suitable for
lab routine because of cost but
especially also because of workload
now more dubai typer over the time
changed the laboratory standard
during the bio-capital identification
the workflow started with abrasion
sample
[Music]
that had to be plated on agar plate
and after colonies have been grown
these were inoculated foreign
biochemical identification and again
normally overnight the identification
procedure had to run to have the result
the next day
so this took one two three days
sometimes more as an example under ropes
and now more the biopiper and most of it
all
proposed to shorten that by one time one
day at least
this would be of course quite an
achievement
comparing
mold of ms with the standards of
former laboratory practice
built clearly advantages
so compared to biochemical id
the quality of results was much better
that was the proposal of people doing
the first studies
it was much faster
it was not as much hand off time
and also the cost per sample
with a certain throughput could be
diminished
sequencing has of course very high
quality of results but on the other hand
it's expensive it's slow takes a lot of
hands on time
so the promise of maori was multibyte
will improve that
here the workflow that shows how easy it
is to use
a colony that is grown on an agar plate
is between 3rd to a multiplate
overlaid with a matrix that's used for
modal analysis
then this target plate is introduced
into a multi-mass vector meter
automatically spectra are acquired and
analyzed for identification
so they look simple but of course behind
that there is a quiet system
there is the morditov mass spectrometer
system
there are dedicated sample preparation
protocols
that are standardized
consumables that support the workflow
software for the acquisition of spectra
but also for data processing and
interpretation
e for each identification run is the
high quality
reference library
application for new resets has to be
supported by application specialists
and they have to be good service because
these systems when they were introduced
into laboratories were totally new and
unknown from the users high technology
not meant to be suitable in the
beginning for a routine lab
so what was needed
and that is something bruce brought in
was system responsibility
with this the promise was
it's not only an easy procedure
it's faster than the old routine it's
more cost effective and it's better
of course this had to be improved
here you see two very important
publications we worked on in the
beginning
to show the quality and robustness of
the system
the first publication
with colleagues from
university hospital in munster in
germany axel melman and professor hansen
showed
that the performance of moderate of mass
spectrometry for a very difficult group
for identification for non-fermented
ground negative bacteria
is similar to the one of 16s rna gene
sequencing
quite remarkable that time
in the second study in 2009 we showed
that it's very reproducible in different
laboratories
for this the same strains were shipped
to laboratories more or less over the
world from united states to russia
and they showed all high quality very
comparable results
in 2009 then also
publication came up that had a lot of
attention from the big lab from
digital wood in marseille
who published the first
routine test of the system
and that said clearly
maldi
is a revolution for microbiology
they tested as you see
high number of strains compared it
to routine and sequencing and concluded
this is a revolution the next step in
microbiology this citation until today
was cited more than 1500 times
then also other early adopters in the
united states started to investigate
and have collected here a number of
early publications about that
people from mayo clinic from nih in 2010
already
carrie ann burnham in washington
university in saint louis
and also the arub laboratories tested
the system
looked at the performance
and reported about it
it all concluded
this works this is an improvement this
can be introduced into the routine and
should be
there was also in 2011 already
publication in cap today where several
adopters reported about mass
spectrometry molecular mass spectrometry
as a tool for infectious disease one of
those in later work from wisconsin
and that
got quite some attention
we developed the system on the io and
ibdc site since many years
always progressively
today you see the species coverage is
near the thousand four thousand
and of the library for europe and
researchers only
and more than 10 000 strains are
contained in
this is not
that did not happen once in a while
but that's a progressive development
over the years its database
extensions and improvements nearly every
year
here the species of the ruo library
that has been extended from less than
two thousand species to near to four
thousand species and with other
libraries that are ibtce labeled it's
now 4000 species that are covered
but database maintenance does not only
mean extension
also what we observe is permanent
changes in microbiology and
microbiological taxonomy
here one example
recently a staphylococcus hemolysicus
was reassigned to be a new species
staphylococcus borealis
this permanently happens new species are
created or defined
species are split into two
sometimes fused
and we have of course to take care that
the database for identification
is always adapted to that this is
permanent work
and this is
always presented then with a new update
each year
well can we say today that the promise
of moldy by driver was kept
we can
no question molded of mass spectrometry
is much faster than the old biochemistry
we talk about less than 10 minutes that
are needed for the identification of
single sample from a colony
in less than an hour for old target
plate
several publications many publications
have shown that the quality is better
than previous biochemical identification
quality
and no question also the cost of
activeness effectiveness also has been
shown here to publication
from united states
that clearly showed
it's cheaper it also saves hand on time
it's cheaper by that
and also faster and effective
so
it was proven that the proposal faster
better and more cost effective is true
today
in 2021
several thousand modified hyper are
installed in microbiology labs
it's today one can say the established
standard for microbial identification
and we can estimate that this year about
120 million identifications worldwide
are performed using the multiply type
120 million that's quite a number
looking at the components of course the
central components first is the mass
spectrometer the up-to-date system of
broker is the multibyte of a series and
series one system
they are state-of-the-art
fast reliable
robust and cost-effective
it's not the system alone of course
there are consumables and accessories
completing it
workflow supporting
disposables and as
accessories
there's of course libraries and also now
an fda cleared reference library for the
multi biter system
ta system
fda clearance started with gram negative
bacteria in 2013
was extended to gram positives and yeast
in 2015 when also unropes were added
looking at the evolution of the mass
spectrometer systems
we started with a system
having a nitrogen laser with 60 hertz
with a quite good throughput of 200
samples about per hour
the laser with a lifetime of about 60
million shots all in the positive ion
mode only
enabling protein measurements
the next important step was the
introduction of the multi byte upper
smart ca system
where a new smart beam laser had been
introduced with 200 hertz so clearly
faster doubling the
throughput per hour
this laser also has a much longer
lifetime is called a
lifetime laser and we further introduced
high performance vacuum system which
enabled a much faster introduction of
the target plate
and to the system and thereby
after having the introduction into the
system also faster start of the
measurement
the newest extension now is the
multivita series and cs1 system
while the bytecode by series 1 ca system
is positive
only
while the multibyte hyperserious has the
positive and the negative ion mode
negative ion mode currently in research
state only is needed for the measurement
especially of lipids that might be new
field expanding the application in
clinical diagnostics in future
still there is the smart beat laser beam
laser that is proven
it can do the same throughput
but
by upgrading the optimized electronics
the sample input and output are still
faster compared to the modified purposes
of smart
complementing the hardware is the
software the motivator ca system
software
this is a very intuitive and easy to use
software
the whole measurement starts just with
registering the target for analysis the
multi-target
the operator also scans in the sample
number into the id field by barcode or
can do it manually
and when the information is entered
at first before the measurement for the
identification a quality control run
with a so-called us-ibd-bts or bacteria
test standard is done
that checks if the quality is okay and
calibrates the system
the run is started
measurement is automated also the
interpretation of the data the
identification
and a report is created
the report is very simple
you see here it gives the sample
and the identified
species together with a log score that
gives the quality
and of course is also electronically
available
looking at the database also the more
divided of the ca system
has made some physical evolution over
the years
i said before we started with
gram-negative bacteria
in the second claim we extended this and
gram-positive bacteria and yeast
and on the bacterial side we extended
from aerobic also to quite a number of
other ropes
in the third claim we extended these
groups again
and then there was a special claim where
we just added one single species i will
talk about later that was candida hours
the first claim later on i will talk
about also in detail was modified
hypersepsi typer
for identification direct from project
blood cultures
and recently we expanded the whole
reference library again in the claim six
and of course we plan to do that further
during the next years like we do it with
the researchers only database
today the fda cleared the database
contains 488 species that are covered by
392 species of species groups this is
the distribution here
in addition there is a additional
library called the non-clinically
validated species library more than two
thousand species in these are not used
for diagnostics but to give a hint about
what could it be to support public
health and guide the selection of a
prayer appropriate test and of course
giving the information for the future
what should be validated in addition
we believe that every microorganism
counts
every microorganism could be of
relevance we just know it after you
found it
so we do continuous expansion and do a
permanent validation and it's easy also
for the user to validate the library
here an example why it's important to
not be biased about
what is relevant
in 2008 a new species was described
called wolfartimona's chitini classica
first clinical cases just two by
sequencing reported in 2009 so at the
end in 2009-2010 nobody knew this
species
we have added it already in 2010 to our
researchers only library
and after some while we got a report
from a user that he found it when you
investigate a sample
in europe that came from a blood culture
very surprising
looking into that it was not so
surprising because this is a bacterium
that lives on flies
eats the chicken or flies
so the external bones as you want
and if a fly visits a wound it can be
transferred to the wound
and this can also lead to bloodstream
infections up to sepsis which happens
later later on that was reported in
several publications i've just collected
several here
and
we have added it also later to the fda
cleared library
by validation
later on we found
that this species even was contained in
our very first claim where we introduced
it could not identify because it was
before wrongly identified by a
biochemical system
so here you see the value of having a
broad database for identification and
permanently doing it up to date
another example for modified hyperlip
library expansion in this case also
adaption of taxonomy
there was a staphylococcus species not
defined
as a species but just on the genus level
by sequencing already in ten thousand
two thousand ten we found that several
times and were submitted
to our library by users
in 2013
a new species was validated
and published called staphylococcus
pedrazi
and we found then that what we had in
the database as a genus the philococcus
only was exactly this species so what we
could do is we could rename it we could
validate it and we could also add it to
the fda cleared library but it's a
partner
a special extension extension as i said
before
was candida hours candada hours was not
known
until 2009.
so 2009 it was first isolated from the
ear channel of a patient nobody thought
it's a bad pathogen
it was described as a person at first in
2011
and then it started to spread across
asia first and europe later it also
appeared in the united states it was
found that its frequently multi-drug
system and it caused
heavy outbreaks in healthcare settings
so here some warning from the cdc on the
home page
we had very early already hundred hours
in our database because of some research
studies we performed with these
specialists
that enabled us to do early auto
validation for ibd usage
actually we agreed for a special
procedure with the fda for that
did an update of the database a thorough
validation
and candida hours was included as a
clear species in the multivitamin
library as the first system that had
this for diagnostic united states
and doing this together with the fda we
developed a procedure that we in future
can much faster include emerging
pathogens into the library and validate
them this is something that's active now
and if something comes up again we
quickly can adopt the database of the
motorbike type ca
and give it in the hands of people for
diagnosis
the second special claim
we have
is
related to sepsis
sepsis is now a real
urgency
in the case of sepsis
every minute counts
it's known that all delay of the proper
treatment decreases
survival
increases morbidity more mortality
so it's very important to have the right
treatment the right antibiotic treatment
at the right time
also having the right treatment means
there is less threat that bacteria get
multi-resistant
coils can be decreased
negative effects on natural flora are
diminished and also unnecessary treated
treatment of a contaminant can be
removed
here you see the workflow previously
for identification of a sepsis pathogen
so first
the sample the blood sample is
introduced into a blood culture button
then incubate it for several hours and
mainly also overnight the growth buff is
performed and then the positive bottle
is flat
and that normally this then is plated on
agar plate again the
blood culture bottle fluid
grown overnight at least for other ropes
maybe two days
and then starting with this growth
again a biochemical identification
earlier was
started again one day
so with introduction of maori for
quantity identification
this saved already one day
but we thought for such an urgency
couldn't we be faster
couldn't we try
to identify directly before plating
from the positive blood culture fluid
we worked on that thoroughly i have to
say very early and i think we can be a
little bit proud about that
this is a poster from 2008 at ikai i
presented that and i think most people
didn't understand what we do because
modded of mass spectrometry in
microbiology at that time in united
states more or less was not known
what we did here is we developed a
protocol with collaboration partners
from clinical laboratories in europe in
europe
to extract
bacteria and yeast
from positive blood cultures by a
two-step procedure using two centrifuges
not
fuel work but about an hour time work
and then identify these isolated
bacteria or yeast
so we got quite good results
and thought this is something future
guiding
later on there were quite a number of
publications with different protocols
to do this to isolate microbes from
project blood culture fluid and do
direct identification with multiply
fiber
but
all the procedures had two disadvantages
one disadvantage to us
it was not a complete system it was left
by the protocols not standardized
but they did it only for laboratory
[Music]
and it was not using a ready-to-use kit
most of them also were
just
a lot of hands-on
and complicated
so we thought about hank how can we
improve that and as a result we have
developed
the multibyte perception timer kit
this is a kit that enabled that enables
the very fast very simple harvesting of
microbes from a positive blood culture
it's a few minutes protocol with two
certification steps both in
microcentrifuge
and
if a direct transfer to the model plate
with a direct measurement does not work
a short extraction procedure can
maybe later on in 10 minutes later
deliver a new result
so very fast only a few minutes
it can be used in batches so the morning
when you have a number of standards or
when just a single sample that is urgent
turns positive
it is ivdc labeled and since 2015 and
just at the end of last year we also got
fda clearance for that
so the workflow now is
that from a positive blood culture this
sample preparation can be done in a few
minutes can be compared against all the
488 species
of the cleared fta cleared multibyte by
ca library
leading to very rapid identification
so this is the notification for our
clearance of multi-bile type and
multivitamin sepsis hyperkit us ibd
in december 2020
the studies for that contained 379
clinical
microbial samples
you see here three sites were
participating
and we could achieve 87.3 correct
identifications we had no fault
identification just no identification
interesting is to have a look
at the details of this study
less than 400 samples analyzed
nevertheless resulted in the detection
of 67 different species
and even 31 different genera you see
that listed here
and if you look in detail
okay three
species
made more than 50 percent of our samples
but then it got more rare
there was 37 species
in less than 400 samples that were
detected with only one isolate in the
study and these eight species detected
with two isolates
three species were even part of the ruo
library only not detected by the fda
library
and three samples could not be
identified even with a reference method
which was
16s rrna gene sequencing
so i guess this is a strong argument for
broad coverage of species diversity
how this helps in clinical practice i
want to show you just
the two examples from europe
where more
is already achieved than the united
states as the ibdc labeling was in 2015.
both examples come from scotland from
the university hospital cross house
in the first example there was a young
lady
just after caesarean section
the wound was red and inflamed and the
blood toucher was taken to check that
an anaerobic blood cutter bottle turned
positive
but there was no organism seen under
microscope while in formal times
what would have been done may be
discharged
luckily
the hospital laboratory performed sepsis
hyper essay
and it identified an anaerobe for the
bacterial nucleation that was important
because the substitute stopped the
patient being incorrectly discharged
by the time when the organism grew on
the culture plate the patient already
had been treated for 48 hours with the
right drug
and she was well enough to be discharged
together with her baby both healthy
i guess quite an achievement good for
the patients
something that makes you happy if you're
happy if you're the developer of such a
sister
the second study
a 30 year old male
was admitted to icu he had a severe
chest infection
the diagnosis was phenomococcal
thermometer
blood culture was collected and her
first treatment was started
corresponding to the first diagnosis
the next morning blood cultures turned
positive the ground stands at its ground
positive streptococci that would be in
line with thermococci
but
in addition of course
luckily
more deceptive was done
and zaps it happens short it's not
normal coxsay it was steppercorpus
biogenus
this
changed the therapy at once
and
that about 24 hours earlier than the
agriculture would have allowed
the physicians related to that
clearly stated
that this was probably life-saving
so these two studies might show you how
powerful the direct identification
simple and rapid using modified hyper
and empty sepsis hyperca can be
as a summary the hospital and patient
benefits are on the patient side clearly
rapid identification allows more
efficient treatment rapid adoption of
therapy reduces morbidity and mortality
and also removes contaminants and
thereby unnecessary treatment
this also leads to benefits for the
hospital because fewer patients have to
be admitted to icu it saves cost it's a
faster treatment with the right drugs
it's a faster identification of alert
organisms and the hospital stays reduced
so we do not stop and now i just to give
you a short preview
what is our next steps
the next claim we are approaching now
will be for microbacteria we have a
powerful researcher's only modified
copper system for identification of
microbacteria in this system
a heat killing is used for these for the
inactivation of microbacteria
and
microbeads are used for suspension of
the microbacteria for the preparation
we now have developed a kit that uses
special tubes with metal cylinders for
the
facile and very quick
suspension of mycobacteria and in
addition an inactivation solution which
also inactivates the microbacteria
without heating
this has created a new workflow which
was
regarded by early testers
as very facile
very fast and preferred we also have
tested now this research was only system
in first studies
about compatibility with a
more divide typer compared it to the old
standard method and as you see here it's
absolutely equivalent works well no
drawback
this will be the next thing for money by
type ca
but it will not only be about micro
bacteria in parallel we will introduce a
new version of the software much faster
than the current one it will have a
special module for the micro bacteria
for adapted measurement and data
analysis but it also will be faster as
fast as the measurement
and it will enable the parallel
measurement and analysis of several
instruments
we have seen that three modified type
series which are very fast can be
analyzed the results can be analyzed in
parallel on one of these software
servers
further we will introduce a subtyping
algorithm that is known from the io
system
in this case for the differentiation of
mycobacterium chimera and either
cellular and this will be the basis for
further subdifferentiations in future
so the expansion and improvement goes on
and we have more ideas for the future
here just a few
there are filamented fungi that we will
approach also highly pathogenic
microorganisms like brucello or french
cellar
we will further implement subtyping and
differentiation with the new algorithm
we also will use that for typing of
resistance and version factors
partially already available ruo and in
europe for ibdce label system
what we're also investigating is lipid
analysis on the multivitable series for
the colistin resistance detection we
just have introduced in europe the first
io system and that will be further
investigated
and later on might be transferred to a
diagnostic system
and another topic very important is the
sample preparation automation before
analysis with more depth and nurses
and of course more to come
so at the end
our view is
that we will expand the multibiotyper
for clinical applications
in very different areas making it a more
central tool in the laboratory
standard identification from colonies as
well as from pod cultures is existing
there are roo
applications already in the pipeline
that are investigated some of them even
available ivdc label to europe
and this will be expanded validated and
also made available in the united states
for the multiply tuppercie system
this all this work in progress
together
with a combination of other technologies
further integration in the laboratory
and sample prep automation
i hope that can report about this during
the next years and that you will also
listen to me and learn about it
with this
i thank you for your attention i thank
all the people of my staff my
collaborators for their great work
and i hope that we continue with this
like we did in the past in the future
thank you for your attention
thank you dr costava for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is it possible to identify shigella
species with current mouthy biotyper
yeah thank you for that question
frequently asked
the system is not intended to do
identification of polar microbial
infections or also contaminations
mixtures
the potential here is also limited
there is research done also on our side
to extend it to some detection of
low complex mixtures like contaminations
of a pure culture
but that will be limited and currently
that's nothing which is available for a
routine
okay thank you
um our next question is
can the moldy be used for the
identification of polymicrobial
infection or contamination
so can you repeat that was that the same
yes um can the molly be used for the
identification of polymicrobial
infection or contamination
i just answered this question sorry
okay
see
what next question what is the timeline
for commercial availability of
susceptibility testing kits for maldi
talk
we're talking here about the quite
stretch time i'm still we're currently
working on the io phase intends to
launch a
own system for collaboration partners
and depending on the outcome
we will go then through validation for
that but that's nothing that can be
expected in a short time for that is too
complex
okay um next question
do you know how the new vipec ms prime
compared to brooker sirius
it's a good question uh but as the
vitamix prime is not really um on the
market yet and not in laboratory that we
know it's hard to answer what i've seen
from the
from the
description of the system and the speed
um
i have to say i'm still the series is
the fastest system obviously for the
overall process the concept is somewhat
different and will be interesting to see
how it compares later on
but we are mainly focusing on what we
are doing ourselves and getting our
system better expanding what we are
doing adding more applications that's
more the focus than doing the permanent
comparison
okay thank you
next question
can
ms be used to identify
carbipenem-resistant
acetanobacter
balmini or
carbo
that
carbapenem-resistant enterobacterialis
probably there is no in the united
states there is no aspect
available for that
in europe we have uh kids on the market
that can detect carbohydrate bases so
not all resistances it's just them
limited to the most threatening one
if bacteria are carrying carbohydrases
this is by a hydrolysis test that
observes by the mass spectrometer the
cleavage of carbopronoms if your
carbonylase is
is um
in the bacterium apparent
but i said that's only available in ivdc
region and not the united states as a
diagnostic currently
okay thank you
um
there is a question will the slides from
this talk be available later on and um
lab routes uh they will have you will
have access to the slides um for two
years after today's date just
to answer that question
um the next question for uh dr koster
zeva
any improvement on limit of detection or
sensitivity
well the limit of detection the
sensitivity of the system
is mainly influenced by sample
preparation and that's where the
improvements have to be done the sample
preparation of chords is also uh
including the sample preparation
before anymore the work and the sample
preparation onto the multi target so the
systems themselves are very
sensitive that is not the main problem
is what you do before and how much do
you get on the multi target and how is
that accessible
and currently
there's work on that of course
but it's not that the other huge
progress compared to the state of the
art
all right thank you
next question in bc
if there is multiple organisms in
culture
what will the maldi report
yeah
i can tell you what we found in the
in the studies and that's also reported
in publications
in most cases
the most prominent
bacterium or microorganism will be
reported it might be that there is no
report there's nothing if they detected
mainly the most important one the most
prominent one will be found and reported
um in some cases a warning is given for
systems that there might be
contamination but
uh normally i said the most prominent
one and there are publications probably
and also in our studies we could confirm
that what does not happen is that
something is created by a plus b gives c
which happens with biochemical systems
in the past so
the worst that can happen is that
nothing can identify
all right next question
please explain the lipid analysis for
bacterial id
okay
so we did not use
that currently in our research for
bacterial id but um as
to to make it brief as bacteria have a
specific protein signature they also
have a in their membrane a lot of lipids
as an example lipidae is a very
important lipid and they are also
characteristic for bacteria and can be
used for some identification purposes
it's a lower content of information
because the complexity is less than for
proteins but it also can be used as an
example for the
detection of holistic resistance because
in this case the lipid a
is modified
um we see but we see also further
potential in
having maybe differentiation in the
lipid side where the protein inside is
limited information so this might be
something where we find in future some
complementarity
okay
next question
in our experience with sepsis type one
milliliter of blood seems insufficient
to get
organism id would you suggest using
higher volume of blood
well
the validation was done with one
milliliter and that is in in the package
insert
of course more would
somehow
but all data obtained with uh one mill
uh
point on the fact that that does not
work if it does not work in your hands
just one mill i think somebody um should
support you to optimize the application
because uh it has to work so this is uh
then might depend on instrument setting
might be uh training necessary but one
will should be sufficient for uh the
results that i've reported and that's
also broadly used in many laboratories
so i would recommend that for this you
contact the broker support that should
help you
all right thank you
next question
for the filamentous database any plan to
submit for fda clearance anytime sooner
also
any plan to include dimorphic fungi into
the database
yeah as mentioned in my
talk at the last slide this is on the
list after micro bacteria we will
approach also others dimorphic hunger we
have to look a little um how we deal
with this because of pathogenesis but in
principle yes that is something on the
roadmap
okay um next
for interest we have identified five
patients
with
wolfartamonas
and ignacinaria
in both wounds and blood cultures in the
last three months all had clinical
correlation with wounds with confirmed
or likely magnet contamination
excellent to have such rapid
identification of these unusual isolates
well that's not a question but at the
end of confirmation what i've reported
and i just can point on that this shows
how something that is regarded
not important or maybe a contaminant
might turn out later as a pathogen and
uh once it has been found and more
people have access to a database and can
find it suddenly it's it's shown that
it's spread over the world it's
something which has also orational for
the infection and it also has an
influence later on treatment so thank
you for confirming that
and
as i said it just supports our idea that
we should not focus only on the most
prevalent and what is thought that is
relevant
okay thank you
um next question
are ms results of cryptococcus species
is inconsistent i.e it might be detected
one day and not detected another
do you have any suggestions on improving
our identification rate
oh sorry about that and i don't have a
direct idea about that and again i would
like to point you on the application
support and specialist that might help
you i would be
surprised if it's not something on the
sample preparation part that can be
improved
um but especially should have a look at
that and i don't want to do something
like a
diagnosis over the video chat
please contact the broker support that's
what they have to do and they're happy
to do
thank you
next question this is a two-part
question
one when do you think the next maldi
biotyper ca system reference library
will be updated again and two
will all future updates also be
applicable
to the mbt septa typer kit u.s ibd
okay
so i guess you're talking about the
ground library that contains the
bacteria and
yeast
i cannot give a clear timeline intention
would be to have a further um update of
this together with the next claim that
we are validating from microbacteria and
that would be also swift and easy to do
then for all the updates um cannot
promise that uh especially in this time
so we still see some
problems uh because of the covet crisis
and timelines quickly are moving
um
so another promise here but the
attention and the second part of the
question could you
repeat it
yes
um
the second part will all future updates
also be applicable
to the mbt
hyper kit that's idp
thank you for i got it
yes
what we do is we always
now will validate what we extend in the
mbtca library
for bacteria and yeast
also for the substitute application
that's in the internal validation
protocol that we have and with claim six
we did this already so we started with a
claim before with a database before for
the validation and then while we work on
the sepsis typer we expanded the library
and we did this already for this claim
so that it's fully validated there's no
distinction between quality
identification and substitute
identification
great
and it looks like we have time
or
one more question
uh
will brooker over time be adding the
species from the non-clinically
validated library
to the fda cleared reference library
of course we would like to move that all
but it's a little bit depending on
availability of strains for the
validation
what we are doing this step-wise as far
as possible
you can imagine there is in our very
large library
that is non-clinically validated and
just for the guidance and public health
and not right and that for the
diagnostics that it's about 2200
and it's hard to get for 2200 species
enough
strains
to build the library and also to do the
validation according to what we have
agreed with the fda to do but we work on
that and step by step we will transfer
whatever we can
into the mbtca library
so fingers crossed and i just can tell
you
we are happy with every customer
who helps us by supplying samples
supplying strains that we can get
progress here
we have quite some partners in a number
of partners here working with us and
collecting such strengths for us and
that is very helpful and at the end
helps everybody who use the system
thank you dr costa zeva for uh do you
have any final comments for the audience
not a lot of final comments but i hope
again that it was interesting for the
audience and they got an impression
about how this evolves this multiply
tupper system and
what it can do and what it will do
hopefully in the future
and i would be very happy if i can
report progress through the next years
and
with that um at the end i think i've
said everything
great well thank you again dr costaseva
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor brooker for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye